cobra kai never dies season five i try to
make it work i had no idea this was out
we went to go see uh d strange two again
yesterday and andrew gordon reminded us
or told us for that matter he's like
did you guys catch the cobra cartridge
what are you talking about here we are catching
up with it uh all the season four reactions are
up here on the channel full length watch for
them for super sexy rejects over our patreon
page along with a bunch of other shows
that we cover over there you guys can
strike hard that like button that would mean a
lot let's see what's going on in this trailer
you set up a bee today is a
turning point at cobra kai
whoa fancy close-up shot and the
only thing better than a full dojo
is a whole valley on full dojos come join us
oh my god oh no this is what we're up against
isn't afraid of putting kids in
harm's way and that's why i have
to take him down you're playing with fire danny
of course i do i'll ask around if anyone saw me
fbi that's the big plan you all get [__] wrong
sometimes females you always have a shot at making
things right hey we're not friends we never will
be there's only one way to end this you have to
cut the head off the sink we have to kill him
wowie wow
yeah hey whoa no no what i didn't
mean literally cut his head off
do it it was a language barrier that's right
man always quick to violence that shows oh man
there's a lot in that trailer an actual televised
commercial to come join cobra [__] is that terry
silver he's got the gold to pay for such
an occasion man such a fancy upgrade for
cobra kai gosh too much it's like globo
gym too much too much sleek and screams
yeah people came to cobra kai for the homespun
aesthetic this is the grounding nature of
cobra kai it feels like a dojo yeah this dude's
taking over man corporations there's going to be
commentary on that that's what we all tune in for
the political commentary adam mckay's cobra kai
season 5. yeah danny's gonna ultimately take
down terry silver with just a rivaling ad
campaign and it looks like they're hinting
at this might be the season where miguel
and robbie finally get along with each
other become brothers become brothers
they're going down to mexico to go rescue
him and it looks like freaking miguel is
i don't want to say getting caught up in
the cartel but it doesn't focus that much
it does look like one of those movies where
yeah like you know we gotta go to mexico
yeah he's mixed up with all the wrong people and
he's doing parkour and decking people with bricks
of cocaine it's got that gritty vibe there and
then yeah our two two white people gonna go in
there and save the day that's what we do rambo
and rambo sun that's right last time absolutely
got a good headband tying sequence for the two of
them but it seems it's like they're having a fight
at freaking miguel's apartment complex yeah i was
gonna say they must bring him back then i mean as
much as you know he's going to come back i was a
little bit like oh damn we're going there already
you're going to show us that much and then of
course you have you know chosen and danny here's
to see what he brings to the table here in terms
of the dynamic because i guess he would still be
personally involved with it it seems like
everyone else had a real personal association
to the main core of this where's chosen's personal
alignment i guess it would be honoree miyagi yeah
it feels like that it's it's it's like i don't
have as many dogs in this fight as you do but
you're basically my dog in this fight so you know
since we have mended our rivalry from the past i
will then take up arms and and help you it's just
cool to see him here absolutely one two i mean the
show is great at taking these characters and then
giving them a lot of nuance and a lot of character
story i hope they do that with chosen and i am
thus excited to see them do that with chosen
because you know there was such a fun reversal
when he showed back up you know subversion of
expectations and it was a really nice story
to watch them mend that relationship and so i
hope that while he's out here yeah we we get some
kind of personal bonding because i mean we've seen
danny do that with johnny and i don't want chosen
to just be a repeat of johnny but i feel like
there's a lot you can do there still there's no
way it'd be a repeat he's a totally different guy
he's much more humbled and aligned with himself he
also had this one shot here speaking of character
nuances but tori looking at her trophy that false
trophy i wonder if she's going to join cope uh
not cobra kai and join me agido at the end yeah
well and what becomes of miyagido and eagle fang
because they got a rebrand or something now you
know and i bet tori will come over to the light
side and then maybe begrudgingly you know make
up with sam i think they're gonna adopt her they
i need to take care of her thing that she
had last season tori's gonna get adopted
caused some awkward situations with the
the boy child what freaking level of
this is mind-melding subconscious purgatory with
salmon yeah that weird void that like the further
for karate you're surrounded by like the specters
of the past what was going on there i don't know
this will be her this will be her darren aronofsky
season it's just going to be all about sam
like spiraling right right and turning to drugs
and like you know beating people up in the streets
well it looks good man it's another season that
i'm very much excited for is it supposed to be
the last i i can we tell those people out there
to make that louder yeah i don't i don't think
the people on the video can hear quite how much
drilling is happening and that's what people come
here for season five cobra kai september instead
of january yeah i miss sacrificing new year's eve
i know right do this maybe now we'll just have
to celebrate and deal with that i can't do that
oh can't take a day off for for a national holiday
screw that no netflix premiere arcane season two
on chris on new year's eve gotta binge it got a
[__] all right guys what are you most looking
forward to hawk he was all over this trailer
yes leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell say hi to miguel for me last but
not least that cartel thing was not racist it was
just talking about the fact that it evokes those
movies that are borderline racist hey let's do it
lance door listen man i was thinking about it
who at our patreon page would i want to apply
the three disciplines of cobra kai to the absolute
most it's got to be you lance you're a firefighter
so instantly that makes my heart sink and i become
intimidated so if we were to engage in a fight i
would strike you first right in the groin i'm a
groin guy i'm the kind of guy who goes right for
there people say cheap shot i go weaken your enemy
impair them as quick as possible strike hard then
i would really strike your face hard afterwards
and then no mercy i pee all over you immediately
afterwards just to really demonstrate how far i
would go to take you down what you don't know is
that i don't drink a lot of water i drink a lot
of acidic things you being a firefighter would
then know i know how to defeat greg you would
set yourself on fire and then tackle me letting
me incinerate but as we all know firefighters
are immune to fire so you wouldn't feel a single
ounce of pain and you would just wash it off
right away and look even better than before you
were let on fire so lance what we've learned
is the way of cobra kai is not the right way